japan's ruling liberal democratic party
the ldp has selected fumio kashida as
the next prime minister
polls show he is not popular with the
public but the fact is that largely
doesn't matter too much given the
dominance of the ldp since 1955.
so members picked a safe moderate choice
to tackle big problems facing the
country from public debt to its
demographic burden because of an
expanding elderly population
following his selection kishida pledged
a new capitalism that would not leave
the middle class behind
i want to raise the income of many
people not just certain groups of people
but as broadly as possible regardless of
where they live or what type of
occupations they may have
i'm sure that will trigger a shift in
expenses in the economy
joining us is jeff kingston a japan
specialist and director of asian studies
at temple university's japan campus jeff
we just heard kashida's pledge to combat
growing income inequality how sincere is
he and how much can he really do on that
front
well it's interesting the uh the two
contenders for leadership both were
implicitly repudiating avenomics arguing
that it led to increased inequalities
and the marginalization of many families
and so basically hobinomics is depicted
by many people as welfare for the
wealthy and so the ldp wants to distance
itself from that legacy of abenomics and
try to pull a plank from the
opposition's platform to say we're going
to unveil programs that address
inequality and the needs of the
vulnerable and so this will play well in
terms of the ldp's image because it
seemed to be the conservative party that
has carried out a series of neo-liberal
reforms that did increase inequality the
problem for kishida will be
is that he essentially is abe's puppet
so how is he going to really do anything
significant particularly since japan's
public debt to gdp ratio is like 260
percent double the level in the united
states so remains to be seen whether you
can really deliver on this but i think
going into the national elections
he really needs to do something
now i want to
follow up on that i mean i'm speaking to
you from germany and you mentioned the
tactics of japan's liberal uh democratic
party to co-opt and adopt the
opposition's most popular policies in
order to maintain its party dominance
it's very reminiscent of angela merkel
and her party but we just saw that
finally catch up to the christian
democrats here do you have a sense of
whether
japan is going to by choosing
the safe choice
and a candidate the public doesn't feel
crazy about will that catch up to the
ldp at some point
maybe at some point but not in the next
national elections everybody's expecting
the ldp will lose some seats uh and so
it's down to how many they'll lose so i
think that what they want to do
is to appeal to floating voters that are
not affiliated with a particular
political party uh so kishida's ploy i
think will work to some extent uh but
people understand the ldp's dna uh
kishida you know doesn't have much
charisma he doesn't light up a room he's
a consensus maker not much of a leader
but he's considered to be steady eddie
safe hands and so i think that's the
image the ldp wishes to convey
now very quickly on foreign policy
more of the same including the same
tougher policy on china
yes i think there's a consensus within
japan that they need to stand up to
china but also i think they're going to
pursue diplomatic initiatives and there
has been speculation that kishida
may make some
outreach to north korea as well but the
u.s alliance will remain central to
japanese security policy and i don't see
any major changes in the offing
jeff kingston thank you so much for
joining us
thank you
you